Thank you everyone for braving the cold
and the snow to be here.
This is six zero,
nine for deep learning for self driving
cars and it's a course where we cover
the topic of deep learning,
which is a set of techniques that have
taken a leap in the last decade for our
understanding of what artificial
intelligence systems are capable of
doing and self driving cars,
which is systems that can take these
techniques and integrate them in a
meaningful,
profound way into our daily lives in a
way that transforms society.
So that's why both of these topics are
extremely important and extremely
exciting.
My name is Lex Friedman and I'm joined
by an amazing team of engineers and Jack
Terwilliger,
Julia Kendall's Burger,
Dan Brown,
Michael Glaser,
lead Ding,
Spencer,
dod,
and Ben antigenic among many others.
We build autonomous vehicles here at
Mit,
not just ones that perceive and move
about the environment,
but ones that interact,
communicate and earn the trust and
understanding of human beings inside the
car,
the drivers and the passengers and the
human beings outside the car,
the pedestrians and other drivers and
cyclists.
The website for this course,
self driving cars that mit did to you,
if you have questions,
email deep cars at Mit Dot Edu,
slack,
deep dash mit for registered mit
students.
You have to register on the website and
by midnight,
Friday,
January 19th,
building your own network and submitted
to the competition that achieves the
speed of 65 miles per hour on the new
deep traffic.
Two point.
Oh,
it's much harder and much more
interesting than last years.
For those of you who participated,
there's three competitions in this
class.
Deep traffic segued,
fuse,
deep crash.
There's guest speakers that come from
Waymo,
Google,
Tesla,
and those are starting new autonomous
vehicle startups in voyage.
You autonomy and Aurora and the news a
lot today from cs and we have shirts for
those of you who brave the snow and
continue to do so towards the end of the
class there'll be free shirts.
Yes.
I said free and in the same sentence you
should be here.
Okay.
First,
the deep traffic competition.
There's a lot of updates and we'll cover
those on Wednesday.
It's a deeper enforcement learning
competition.
Last year we received over 18,000
submissions.
This year we're going to go bigger.
Not only can you control one car,
well then you will now work.
You can control up to 10.
This is multiagent,
deeper enforcement learning.
This is super cool.
Second,
psych fuse,
dynamic driving scene segmentation
competition where you're given the raw
video,
the the kinematics of the vehicles and
the movement of the vehicle,
the state of the art segmentation for
the training set you're given ground
truth labels,
pixel level labels,
scene segmentation and optical flow and
would those pieces of data your task to
try to perform better than the state of
the art in image based segmentation.
Why is this critical and fascinating and
open research problem?
Because robots that act in this world
and the physical space not only must
interpret,
use these deep learning methods to
interpret the spacial visual
characteristics of a scene,
they must also interpret,
understand and track the temporal
dynamics of the scene.
This competition is about temporal
propagation of information,
not just seen as segmentation.
You must understand the space and time
and finally,
deep crash where we use deeper
enforcement learning.
The Slam cars thousands of times at uh,
at,
uh,
here at Mit,
at the gym,
you're given data on a thousand runs or
car or a car knowing nothing is using a
monocular camera as a single input,
driving over 30 miles an hour through a
scene that has very little control
through very little capability to
localize itself.
It must act very quickly in that scene.
You're given a thousand runs to learn
anything.
We'll discuss this in the coming weeks.
This competition will result in for
submissions that we evaluate everyone's
in simulation,
but the taskforce submissions we put
head to head at the gym and until there
is a winner declared what keep slamming
cars at 30 miles an hour deep crash and
also on the website is from last year.
And on get hub,
there's deep tesla,
which is using the large scale
naturalistic driving data set.
We have to train a neural network to do
end to end steering.
It takes in monocular video from the
forward roadway and produce the steering
commands that steering commands for the
car
lectures.
Today we'll talk about deep learning
tomorrow.
We'll talk about autonomous vehicles
drls on Wednesday,
driving,
seeing,
understanding,
so segmentation,
that's Thursday.
On Friday we have Sasha or knew the
director of engineering at Waymo.
Waymo is one of the companies that's
truly taking huge strides and fully
autonomous vehicles.
They're taking the fully l four l five
autonomous vehicle approach and it's
fascinating to learn.
He's also the head of perception for
them to learn from him what kind of
problems they're facing,
what kind of approach they're taking on.
We have a meal.
If Rizzoli,
who won to last year,
speakers start to ask.
Carmen said,
Amelia is the smartest person who knows,
so Amelia for is the cto of autonomy and
autonomous vehicle,
a company that was just acquired by
Delphi for a large sum of money and
they're doing a lot of incredible work
in Singapore and here in Boston.
Next Wednesday we are going to talk
about the topic of our research or my
personal fascination is deep learning
for drivers,
states sensing,
understanding the human perceiving,
everything about the human being inside
the car,
outside the car.
One Talk I'm really excited about is
Oliver Cameron.
On Thursday,
he is now the CEO of of autonomous
vehicle startup voyage.
He was previously the director of the
self driving car program free udacity.
He will talk about how to start a self
driving car company.
For those it said that Mit folks and
entrepreneurs,
if you want to start one yourself,
they'll tell you exactly how it's super
cool and then sterling Anderson who was
the director previously,
a tesla autopilot team and now is the
cofounder of Aurora,
the car,
the self driving car startup that I
mentioned that has now partnered with
Nvidia and many others,
so why self driving cars?
Those classes about applying data driven
learning methods to the problem of
autonomous vehicles.
Why self driving cars are fascinating
and interesting problem space quite
possibly in my opinion,
this is the first wide reaching and
profound integration of personal robots
in society wide reaching because there's
1 billion cars on the road.
Even a fraction of that will change
the face of transportation and how we
move about the world profound,
and this is an important point that's
always understood,
is there's an intimate connection
between a human and a vehicle.
When there's a direct transfer of
control,
it's a direct transfer of control that
takes that his or her life into the
hands of an artificial intelligence
system.
I showed a few quick,
quick,
quick clips here you can google first
time with Tesla,
autopilot on Youtube,
and watch people perform that transfer
of control.
There's something magical about a human
and a robot working together that will
transform what artificial intelligence
is in the 21st century and this
particular autonomous system,
ai system,
self driving cars,
is on the scale and the profound,
the life critical nature of it is
profound in a way that will truly test
the capabilities of Ai.
There is a personal connection that will
argue throughout these lectures that we
cannot escape.
Considering the human being,
that autonomous vehicle must not only
perceive and control its movement
through the environment.
It must also perceive everything about
the human driver and the passenger and
interact,
communicate,
and build trust with that driver.
Because in my view,
as I will argue throughout this course,
an autonomous vehicle is more of a
personal robot than it is a perfect
perception control system.
Because perfect perception and control,
so this world full of humans is
extremely difficult and could be two,
three,
four decades away,
full autonomy.
Autonomous Vehicles are going to be
flawed,
they're going to have flaws and we'll
have to design systems that are
effectively caught effectively transfer
control to human beings when they can't
handle the situation,
and that transfer of control isn't as a
fascinating opportunity for ai because
the obstacle avoidance perception of
obstacles,
an obstacle avoidance is the easy
problem.
It's the safe problem.
Going 30 miles an hour and navigating
through streets of Boston is easy.
It's when you have to get to work in
your late or you're sick of the person
in front of you that you want to go into
the er in the opposing lane and speed
up.
That's human nature and we can't escape
it are artificial assist intelligence
systems can't escape human nature.
They must work with it.
What's shown here is one of the
algorithms will talk about next week for
cognitive load or we take the raw 3d
accomplished in your networks,
taken the eye region,
the blinking,
and the pupil movement to determine the
cognitive load of the driver.
We'll see how we can detect everything
about the driver,
where they're looking.
Emotion,
cognitive load,
body pose,
estimation,
drowsiness,
the the.
The movement towards full autonomy is so
difficult.
I would argue that it almost requires
human level intelligence that the,
as I said,
two,
three,
four decade out journey for artificial
intelligence researchers to achieve full
autonomy will require achieving,
solving some of the problems,
fundamental problems of creating
intelligence,
and that's something we'll discuss in
much more depth in a broader view in two
weeks.
For the artificial general intelligence
course where we have Andrea neuropathy
from Tesla,
Ray Kurzweil,
Mark Robert from Boston,
dynamics who asked for the dimensions of
the room because he's bringing robots.
Nothing else was told to me,
it'll be a surprise.
So that is why I argued the human
centered artificial intelligence
approach in every algorithm design
considers the human
for autonomous vehicle on the left,
the perception seen understanding,
and the control problem as we'll explore
through the competitions and the
assignments of this course can handle 90
and increasing percent of the cases,
but it's the ten one point one percent
of the cases as we get better and better
that we have to,
we're not able to handle to these
methods.
And that's where the human perceiving
the human is really important.
This is the video from last year of Arc
de Triomphe.
Thank you.
I didn't know what last year.
I know now.
That's one of millions of cases where
human to human interaction is the is the
dominant driver,
not the basic perception control
problem.
So why deep learning in this space,
because deep learning is a set of
methods that do well from a lot of data
and to solve these problems or human
life is a stake.
We have to be able to have techniques
that learn from data,
learn from real world data.
This is the fundamental reality of
artificial intelligence systems that
operate in the real world.
They must learn from real world data,
whether that's on the left,
the perception,
the control side,
on the right for the human,
the perception and the communication,
interaction and collaboration with the
human and the human robot interaction.
Okay,
so what is deep learning?
It's a set of techniques.
If you allow me the definition of
intelligence being the ability to
accomplish complex goals,
then I would argue definition of
understanding,
maybe reasoning is the ability to turn
complex information into simple,
useful,
actionable information and that is what
deep learning does.
Deep learning is representation,
learning or feature learning,
if you will.
It's able to take raw information,
raw complicated information that's hard
to do.
Anything with and construct here are
hierarchical representation of that
information to be able to do something
interesting with it.
It is the branch of artificial
intelligence which is most capable and
focused on this task.
For me,
representations from data,
whether it's supervised and
unsupervised,
whether it's with the help of humans or
not,
it's able to construct structure,
find structure in the data such that you
can extract simple,
useful,
actionable information.
On the left for me in Goodfellas book is
the basic example of a
misclassification,
the input of the image on the bottom
with the raw pixels,
and as we go up the stack as a go up,
the layers hiring higher order
representations of formed from edges to
contours the corners to object parts,
and then finally the full object
semantic classification of what's in the
image.
This is representation learning.
A favorite example for me
is one from for centuries ago,
our place in the universe and
representing that place in the universe,
whether it's relative to Earth,
are relative to the sun.
On the left is our current belief.
On the right is the one that is held
widely for centuries ago.
Representation matters because what's on
the right is much more complicated than
what's on the left.
You can think of in a simple case here,
when the task is to draw a line that
separates green triangles and blue
circles in the cartesian coordinate
space on the left,
the task is much more difficult.
Impossible to do well on the right is
trivial.
In polar coordinates,
this transformation is exactly what we
need to learn.
This is representation learning so you
can take the same task of having to draw
a line that separates the blue curve and
the red curve on the left.
If we draw a straight line,
it's going to be a high.
There is no way to do it was zero error
with 100 percent accuracy.
Shown on the right is our best attempt,
but what we can do with deep learning
with a single hidden layer network done
here is formed the the topology,
the mapping of the space in such a way
in the middle that allows for a straight
line to be drawn.
This separates the blue curve and the
red curve.
The learning of the function in the
middle is what we're able to achieve
with deep learning.
It's taking raw,
complicated information and making it
simple,
actionable,
useful,
and the point is that this kind of
ability to learn from raw sensory
information means that we can do a lot
more with a lot more data,
so deep learning gets better with more
data
and that's important for real world
applications
were edge cases are everything.
This is us driving to perception control
systems.
One is an tesla vehicle with the
autopilot version one system that's
using a monocular camera to perceive the
external environment and produce control
decisions and our own neural network
running an adjustment [inaudible] that's
taking in the same with a monocular
camera and producing controlled
decisions and the two systems argue and
when they disagree,
they raise up a flag to say that this is
an edge case.
These that needs human intervention.
There is covering such edge cases using
machine learning is the main problem,
our artificial intelligence and in when
applied to the real world,
it is the main problem to solve.
Okay,
so what are neural networks inspired?
Very loosely,
and I'll discuss about the key
difference here in our own brains and
artificial brains because there's a lot
of insights in that difference,
but inspired loosely by biological
neural networks.
Here is a simulation of a
thalamocortical brain network,
which is only 3 million neurons,
476 million synapses.
The full human brain is a lot more than
that 100 billion neurons.
One thousand trillion synapses.
There's inspirational music with this
one that I didn't realize was here
should make you think artificial neural
networks.
Yeah,
let's just let it play.
The.
The human neural network is 100 billion
neurons,
right?
One thousand trillion synapses,
one of the state of the state of the art
neural networks as resident at 1:52,
which has $60,
million synapses.
That's a difference of about a seven
order of magnitude difference.
The human brains have 10 million times
more synapses than artificial neural
networks plus or minus one order of
magnitude depending on the network.
So what's the difference between a
biological neuron and artificial neuron?
The topology of the human brain have no
layers.
Neural networks are stacked and layers,
they're fixed for the most part.
There is chaos.
Very little structure in our human brain
in terms of Han neurons are connected.
They're connected often to 10,000
plus other neurons.
The number of synopsis from individual
neurons that are,
uh,
that are input into the neuron is huge.
There are asynchronous.
The human brain brain works
asynchronously.
Artificial neural networks work
synchronously.
The learning algorithm for artificial
neuron networks,
the only one,
the best one is backpropagation.
And we don't know how human brains learn
processing speed.
This is one of the,
the only benefits we have with
artificial neural networks is artificial
neurons are faster,
but they're also extremely power and
efficient.
And there is a division into stages of
training and testing when you're on that
works,
uh,
with,
biological neural networks is,
you're sitting here today,
they're always learning.
The only profound similarity,
the inspiring one,
the captivating one,
is that both are distributed computation
at scale.
There is an emergent aspect to neural
networks where the basic element of
computation,
a neuron is simple,
is extremely simple,
but when connected together,
beautiful,
amazing,
powerful,
approximators can be formed.
A neural network is built up with these
computational units where the inputs,
there's a set of edges with weights on
them.
The edges are the weights are by this
input signal.
A bias is added with a nonlinear
function that determines whether the
network gets activated or not.
The neuron gets activated or not
visualized here,
and these neurons can be combined in a
mall in number of ways.
It can form a feed forward and will not
work or they can feed back into itself
to form to have state memory in
recurrent neural networks.
The ones on the left are the ones that
are most successful for most
applications in computer vision.
The ones in the right are very popular
and specific when temporal dynamics or
dynamics time series of any kind are
used.
In fact,
the ones in the right a much closer to
the way our human brains are and the
ones on the left,
but that's why they're really hard to
train.
One beautiful aspect of this emerging
power from multiple neurons being
connected together is the universal
property that with a single hidden
layer,
these networks can learn any function,
learn to approximate at any function
which is an important property to be
aware of because the limits here are not
in the power of the networks.
The limits in the is in the methods by
which we construct them and train them.
What kinds of machine learning deep
learning are there.
We can separate into two categories,
memorizers now,
uh,
the approaches that essentially memorize
patterns in the data and approaches that
we can loosely say are beginning to
reason to generalize over the data with
minimal human input.
On top,
on the left are the quote unquote
teachers is how much human input and
blue is needed to make the method
successful for supervised learning,
which is what most of the deep learning
success has come from.
Or most of the data's annotated by human
beings.
The human is at the core of the success.
Most of the data that's part of the
training needs to be annotated by human
beings was some additional successes
coming from augmentation methods that
extend that extend the data based on
which is networks have trained and the
semi-supervised reinforcement learning
and unsupervised methods that we'll talk
about later in the course.
That's where the near term successes we
hope are and where the unsupervised
learning approaches,
that's where the true excitement about
the possibilities of artificial lie
being able to make sense of our world
with minimal input from humans.
So we can think of two kinds of deep
learning impacts spaces.
One is a special purpose intelligence is
taking a problem,
formalizing it,
collecting enough data on it,
and being able to solve a particular
case that's that provides value of
particular interest.
Here is a a network that estimates
apartment costs in the Boston area,
so you could take the number of
bedrooms,
the square feet and the neighborhood and
provide is.
I'll put the estimated costs on the.
On the right is the actual data of
apartment cost.
We're actually standing at a in a area
that has over $3,000
for a studio apartment.
Some of you may be feeling that pain and
then there's general purpose
intelligence or something that feels
like approaching general purpose
intelligence,
which is reinforcement and unsupervised
learning.
Here with Andrea,
come from Monica potties Pong,
the pixels,
a system that takes in 80 by 80 pixel
image and with no other information is
able to beat,
is able to win at this game,
no information except a sequence of
images,
raw sensory information,
the same way,
the same kind of information that human
beings taken from the visual,
audio touch,
sensory data,
the very low level data and be able to
learn to win and this very simplistic
and it's very artificially constructed
world,
but nevertheless a world where no
feature learning is performed.
Only raw sensory information is used to
win with very sparse minimal human
input.
We'll talk about that on Wednesday.
We're deep reinforcement learning so but
for now we'll focus on supervised
learning where there is input data,
there is a network.
We're trying to train a learning system
and there's a correct output that's
labeled by human beings,
that's the general training process for
neural network input,
data labels and the training of that
network,
that model,
so that in the testing stage,
our new input data that has never seen
before as task with producing guesses
and is evaluated based on that for
autonomous vehicles,
that means being released either in
simulation or in the real world to
operate
and how they learn,
how neural networks learn is given the
forward pass of taking the input data,
whether it's from the training stage,
in the training stage,
the taking the input data,
producing a prediction,
and then given that there's ground truth
in the training stage,
we can,
we can have a measure of error based on
a loss function that then punishes the,
uh,
the synapses,
the connections,
the parameters that were involved with
making that a,
that wrong prediction.
A back propagates the error through
those weights.
We'll discuss that a little bit more
detail in a bit here.
So what can we do with deep learning?
You can do one to one mapping.
Really,
you can think of input as being
anything.
It can be a number of vector numbers,
a sequence of numbers,
a sequence of vector,
of numbers,
anything you can think of from images to
video to audio to text and represented
in this way,
and the output can the same be a single
number or it can be images,
video,
text,
audio,
one to one,
mapping on the bottom,
one to many,
many to many to many and many to many
with different starting points for the
data,
a synchronous,
some quick terms that will come up.
Deep learning is the same as neural
networks.
It's really deep neural networks,
large neural networks.
It's a subset of machine learning that
has been extremely successful in the
past decade.
Multilayer Perceptron,
deep neural network,
recurrent neural network,
long short term memory network,
Lstm,
convolutional neural network,
and deep belief networks.
All of these will come up through the
slides and there is specific operations
layers within these networks of
convolution pooling activation and
backpropagation.
This concepts that we'll discuss in this
class,
activation functions.
There's a lot of variance than the left
is the activation function and left
column,
and the x axis is the input.
On the y axis is the output,
the sigmoid function,
the output.
If the font is too small,
the output is not centered at zero.
For the Tan age function,
it's centered at zero,
but it's still suffers from vantage
ingredients.
Vanishing gradients is one of the value.
The input is low or high.
The,
uh,
the output of the network,
because you see in the right column
there,
the derivative of the function is very
low,
so the learning rate is very low for
revenue,
not it's also not zero centered,
but it does not suffer from vanishing
gradients.
Backpropagation is the process of
learning.
It's the way we take go from error
computers,
the last function and bottom right of
the slide,
taking the actual output of the network
with the Ford Pass,
subtracting it from the ground truth
squaring dividing were to and using that
lost function than back propagate
through to construct a great aunt to
back propagate the error to the weights
that we're responsible for making either
correct or incorrect decision.
So the subtests that there's a forward
pass as a backward pass and a fraction
of the weights,
gradients of tractor from the weight,
that's it.
That process is modular,
so it's local to each individual neuron,
which is why it's extremely dis.
We're able to distribute it across
multiple across the GPU parallelize
across the GPU,
so learning for a neural network.
These competition units are extremely
simple,
extremely simple to then correct when
they make an error,
when they're part of a larger network
that makes an error and all that boils
down to is essentially an optimization
problem where the objective utility
function is the loss function and the
goal is to minimize it and we have to
update the parameters,
the weights and the synapses and the
biases to decrease that loss function.
And that last function is highly
nonlinear.
Depending on the activation functions,
different properties,
different issues arise.
There's vanishing gradients for sigmoid
where the learning can be slow.
There's dying.
Rarely use where the derivatives exactly
zero,
four inputs less than zero.
There are solutions to this like leaky
rallies and a bunch of details that you
may discover when you try to win the
deep traffic competition,
but for the most part these are the main
activation functions and it's the choice
of the you'll network designer,
which one works best.
They're saddle points,
all the problems from numerical,
nonlinear optimization that arise come
up here.
It's hard to break symmetry and
stochastic gradient descent without any
kind of tricks to it can take a very
long time to arrive at the minimum.
One of the biggest problems in all of
machine learning and certainly in deep
learning is overfitting.
You can think of the blue dots and
applied here as the data to which we
want to fit a curve.
We want to design a learning system that
approximates the aggression of that,
uh,
of this data.
So in green is a sine curve,
simple fits well,
and then there's a ninth degree
polynomial which fits even better in
terms of the error,
but it clearly over fits this data.
If there's other data that has not seen
yet that it has to fit,
it's likely to produce a high error,
so it's overfitting.
The training set.
This is a big problem for small data
sets and so we have to fix that with
regularization.
Regularization is a set of methodologies
that prevent overfitting learning the
training too well in order and then to
not be able to generalize to the testing
stage and overfitting.
The main symptom is the air decreases in
training set but increases in the test
set,
so there's a lot of techniques and
traditional machine learning that deal
with this and cross validation,
so on,
but because of the cost of training for
neural networks,
it's traditional to use of what's called
the validation set,
so you create a subset of the training
they use,
keep away for which you have the ground
truth and use that as a representative
of the testing set so you perform early
stoppage or more realistically.
Just save a checkpoint often to see how
as the training evolves,
the performance changes on the
validation set and so you can stop when
the performance and the validation set
is getting a lot worse.
It means you're overtraining on the
training set.
In practice,
of course,
we run training which longer and see
when a,
what is the best performing,
uh,
what,
what is the best performing snapshot
checkpoint of the network dropout is
another very powerful regularization
technique.
What were you randomly remove?
Part of the network.
Randomly remove some of the nodes in the
network along with its incoming and
outgoing edges.
So what that really looks like is a
probability of keeping a node and in
many deep learning frameworks today,
it comes with a dropout layer.
So it's essentially a probability that's
usually greater than point five than a,
that a node will be kept for the input
layer,
the probability should be much higher or
more effectively.
What works well is just adding noise.
What's the point here?
You want to create enough diversity in
the training data such that it is
generalizable to the testing and as
you'll see with deep traffic,
competition is l two and l one penalty
weight decay way penalty where there's a
penalization on the weights.
They get too large.
The [inaudible] penalty keeps the
weights small unless the aero derivative
is huge and produces a smoother model
and prefers to distribute when there is
too similar inputs.
That prefers to put half the weights on
each distribute the weights as opposed
to putting the weight on one of the
edges,
makes the network more robust.
Our one penalty has the one benefit that
for really large weights,
they're allowed to be to stay,
so it's allows her a few ways to remain
very large.
These are the regularization techniques
and I wanted to mention them because
they're useful to some of the
competitions here in the course and I
recommend to go to a playground and
tenser and tenser flow playground to
play around with some of these
parameters where you get to online,
in the browser,
play around with different inputs,
different features,
different number of layers and
regularization techniques,
uh,
and to build your intuition about
classification,
regression problems given different
input data sets.
So what changed why over the past many
decades,
neural networks that have gone through
two winters are now again dominating the
artificial intelligence community CPU
GPU,
a six.
So computational power has skyrocketed
from Moore's law to gps.
There is huge data set including image
net and others.
There is research backpropagation in the
eighties,
uh,
the convolutional neural networks,
Lstm,
there's been a lot of interesting
breakthroughs about how to design these
architectures,
how to build them such that they're
trainable,
efficiently using gps.
There is the software infrastructure
from being able to share the data will
get to being able to train networks and
share code and effectively view neural
networks as a stack of layers as opposed
to having to start from scratch with
tensorflow,
Pi Torch and other than that and other
deep learning frameworks and there's
huge financial backing from Google,
facebook and so on.
Deep learning is it in order to
understand why it works so well and
where it's limitations are,
we need to understand where our own
intuition comes from about what is hard
and what is easy.
The important thing about computer
vision,
which is a lot of what this course is
about even as in deeper enforcement
learning formulation,
is that visual perception for us human
beings was formed 540 million years ago.
That's $540.
Millions million years worth of data and
abstract thought is only formed a a
100,000
years ago.
That's several orders of magnitude less
data so we can with neural networks
predictions that seemed trivial.
The,
uh,
the trivial to us human beings,
but completely challenging and wrong to
neural networks.
Here on the left showing a prediction of
a dog with a little bit of a distortion
and noise added to the image,
producing the image on the right and you
know,
network is confidently 99 percent plus
accuracy predicting that it's an ostrich
and there's all these problems as to
deal with whether it's an computer
vision data,
whether it's in text,
data,
audio,
all of this variation arises in vision.
It's elimination variability.
The set of pixels in the numbers look
completely different depending on the
lighting conditions.
It's the biggest problem.
And driving is lighting conditions.
Letting variability pose variation.
Objects need to be learned from every
different perspective.
I'll discuss that for when sensing the
driver.
Most of most of,
most of the deep learning work that's
done in the face on the human is done on
the frontal face or semi frontal face.
That has very little work done on the
full three 60 a pose variability that a
human being can take on.
Interclass variability for the
classification problem,
for the detection problem,
there is a lot of different kinds of
objects for cats,
dogs,
cars,
bicyclists,
pedestrians,
so that brings us to object
classification and I'd like to take you
through where deep learning has taken
big strides for the past several years
leading up to this year to 2018.
So let's start at object classification
is when you take a single image and you
have to say one class that's most likely
to belong in that image.
The most famous variant of that as the
image net competition.
Image net challenge image not data set
is a data set of 14 million images with
21,000
categories and for say the category of
fruit,
there's a total of 188,000
images of fruit and there is 1200 images
of granny smith apples.
It gives you a sense of what we're
talking about here.
So this is been the source of a lot of
interesting breakthroughs in deep
learning and a lot of the excitement and
deep learning is first.
The big successful network,
at least one that became famous and deep
learning is Alex Net in 2012.
That took a leap of a significant leap
in performance on the image net
challenge,
so it was one of the first neural
networks that have successfully trained
on the GPU and achieved an incredible
performance boost over the previous
year.
On the image net challenge.
The challenges,
and I'll talk about some of these
networks,
is to given a single image,
give five guesses,
and you have five guests.
This to guess for one of them to be
correct.
The human annotation is the question
often comes up.
So how do you know the ground truth?
Human level of performance is five point
one percent accuracy on this task,
but the way the annotation for image net
is performed is there's a google search
where you pull the images are already
labeled for you,
and then the annotation that on
mechanical Turk,
other humans perform.
It's just binary.
Is this a cat or not a cat?
So they're.
They're not tasked with performing the
very high resolution semantic labeling
of the image.
Okay.
So through from 2012 with Alex Net to
today and the big transition in 2018 of
the image net challenge leaving Stanford
and go into Cagle,
it's sort of a monumental step because
in 2015 with the resident network was
the first time that the human level
performance was exceeded and I think
this is a very important
map of where deep learning is for
particular what I would argue as a toy
example,
despite the fact that it's 14 million
images.
So we're developing state of the art
techniques here and the next stage as we
are now exceeding human level
performance on this task is how to take
these methods into the real world to
perform scene perception,
to perform driver's state perception
in 2016 and 2017.
See you image and see net has a very
unique new addition to the previous
formulations that has achieved an
accuracy of two point two percent error,
two point two,
five percent error on the image net
declassification challenge.
This is an incredible result.
Okay,
so you have this image classification
architecture that takes in a single
image and produces convolution,
uh,
and uh,
it takes it through pool and convolution
and at the end fully connected layers
and performance,
the classification task or regression
task,
and you can swap out that layer to
perform any kind of,
um,
other task including with the recurrent
neural networks of image captioning and
so on,
or localization of bonding boxes.
Or you can do fully convolutional
networks,
which we'll talk about on Thursday,
which is when you take a,
a images and input and producing images
that output.
But where the output image in this case
is the segmentation is a wear a color
indicates what,
ah,
what the object is of the category of
the,
of the object.
So it's level of segmentation.
Every single pixel in the image is
assigned a class of category of where
that pixel belongs to.
This is the kind of task that's overlaid
on top of other sensory information
coming from the car.
In order to perceive the external
environment,
you can continue to extract information
from images in this way to produce image
to image mapping.
For example,
to colorize images and take from gray
scale images to color images or you can
use that kind of heat map information to
localize objects in the image,
so as opposed to just classifying that
this is an image of a of a cow are CNN
fast and faster.
Our CNN and a lot of other localization
networks allow you to propose different
candidates for where exactly the car was
located in this image and thereby being
able to perform object detection,
not just object classification in 2017
has been a lot of cool applications of
these architectures.
One of which is back on removal.
Again,
mapping from image to image,
ability to remove a background from
selfies of humans or human like
pictures of faces.
The references with some incredible
animations are in the bottom of the
slide and the slides are now available
online.
Big Stupid Hd.
There's been a lot of work in gans
generative artifice.
Ariel networks in particular in driving
gans have been used to generate examples
that generate examples from source data.
Whether that's from raw data or in this
case with pics to picks.
Hd is taking course,
semantic labeling of the images,
pixel level and producing photo
realistic,
high definition images of the forward
roadway.
This is an exciting possibility for
being able to generate a variety of
cases for self driving cars,
for autonomous vehicles to be able to
learn to generate,
to augment the data and be able to
change the way different rows look,
road conditions to change the way
vehicles look,
cyclists,
pedestrians.
Then we can move on to recur in your own
networks.
Everything I've talked about was one to
one,
mapping from image to image or image to
number,
but currently all networks or work with
sequences.
We can use sequences to generate
handwriting to generate text captions
from an image based on the localization
is the various detections in that image.
What can provide video description
generation,
so taking a video and combining
convolution neural networks with
recurrent neural networks,
using convolutional neural networks to
extract features frame to frame and
using those extracted features to input
into our the rns to then generate a a,
a labeling,
a description,
what's going on in the video.
A lot of exciting approaches for
autonomous systems,
especially in drones were the time to
make a decision a is short,
same with the RC car,
traveling 30 miles an hour at tensional
mechanisms for steering the attention of
the network had been very popular for
the localization task and for just
saving how much interpretation of the
image,
how many pixels need to be considered in
the classification task so we can steer,
we can model the way a human being looks
around and image to interpret it and use
the network to do the same and we can
use that kind of steering to a draw
images as well.
Finally,
the big breakthroughs in 2017 came from
this,
the pong to pixels,
the reinforcement learning,
using sensory data,
raw sensory data,
and use reinforcement learning methods
deeper.
All methods of which we'll talk about on
Wednesday.
I'm really excited about the underlying
methodology of deep traffic and deep
crash is using neural networks as the
approximators inside reinforcement
learning approaches.
So Alphago in 2016 have achieved a
monumental task that when I first
started in artificial intelligence was
told to me it was impossible for any
system to accomplish,
which is to win at the game of go
against the top human player in the
world.
However,
that method was trained on human expert
positions.
The alphago system was trained on
previous games played by human experts
and an incredible accomplishment.
Alphago zero in 2017 was able to beat
Alphago and many of its variance by
playing itself from zero information.
So no knowledge of human experts,
no games,
no training data,
very little human input.
And what more it was able to generate
moves that were surprising to human
experts.
I think it's Einstein that said that
intelligence,
that the key mark of intelligence is
imagination.
I think it's beautiful.
See an artificial intelligence system
come up with something that surprises
human experts,
truly surprises
for the gambling junkies.
Deep Stack and a few other variants have
been used in 2017 to when a heads up
poker.
Again,
another incredible results.
I was always told and artificial
intelligence will be impossible for dave
for any machine learning method to
achieve and it was able to beat a
professional player and several
competitors have come along since we're
yet to be able to beat to win a
tournament setting.
So multiple players,
for those of you familiar heads up,
poker is one on one.
It's a much,
much smaller,
easier space to,
uh,
solve.
There's a lot more humidity,
human dynamics going on from when
there's multiple players,
but that's the task for 2018
and the drawbacks.
So one of my favorite videos,
a show it often have coast runners for
these deep reinforcement learning
approaches.
The learning of the reward function,
the definition of the word function
controls how the actual system behaves.
And this will come.
This will be extremely important for us
with autonomous vehicles.
Here the boat is tasked with gaining the
highest number of points and it figures
out that it does not need to race,
which is the whole point of the game in
order to gain points.
But instead pickup green circles that
regenerate themselves over and over.
This is the the counter intuitive
behavior of a system that would not be
expected when you first designed the
reward function,
and this is a very formal simple system,
nevertheless is extremely difficult to
come up with a reward function that
makes it operate in the way you expected
to operate.
Very applicable for autonomous vehicles
and of course on the perception side,
as I mentioned with the hostage and the
dog,
a little bit of noise.
The 99 point six percent confidence,
we can predict that the noise up top is
a robin,
a Cheetah,
Armadillo,
lesser panda.
These are outputs from actual state of
the art and neural networks
taking into noise and producing a
confident prediction.
It should build our intuition to
understand that we don't,
that the visual characteristics,
the vision,
the special characteristics of an image
that not necessarily convey the level of
hierarchy necessary to function in this
world in a similar way with a dog and
the ostrich and everything in an ostrich
and network confidently with a little
bit of noise can make the wrong
prediction.
Thinking the bus is an ostrich and as an
ostrich,
they're easily fooled,
but not really because they performed
the task that they were trained to do
well,
so we have to make sure we keep our
intuition
optimized to the way machines learn,
not the way humans have learned over the
540 million years of data that we've
gained through developing the eye,
the revolution,
the current challenge is we're taking on
first transfer learning.
There's a lot of success in transfer
learning between domains that are very
close to each other,
so image classification from one domain
to the next.
There's a lot of value in forming
representations of the way scenes look
in order to see natural scenes look in
order to do scene segmentation,
the driving case,
for example,
but we're not able to do any any bigger
leaps in the way we perform transfer
learning.
The biggest challenge for deep learning
is to generalize,
generalize across domains.
It lacks the ability to reason and the
way that we've defined understanding
previously,
which is the ability to turn complex
information into simple,
useful information,
convert domain specific complicated
sensory information that doesn't relate
to the initial training set.
That's the open challenge for deep
learning,
training,
very little data,
and then go and reason and operate in
the real world right now.
You know now it's a very inefficient.
They're acquiring a big data.
They require supervised data,
which means they need human costs,
the human input.
They're not fully automated despite the
fact that the feature learning
incredibly,
the big breakthrough feature learning is
performed automatically.
You're still have to do a lot of design
or the actual architecture of the
network and all the different hyper
parameter tuning and he used to perform
human input perhaps a little bit more
educated human input and former phd
students.
Postdocs faculty is required to high
during these hyper parameters,
but nevertheless human input is still
necessary.
They cannot be left alone.
For the most part,
their award defining the award is with
south coast.
Ron is extremely difficult for systems
that operate in the real world.
Transparency quite possibly is not an
important one,
but neural networks currently our black
box for the most part,
they're not able to accept through a few
successful visualization methods that
visualize different aspects of the
activations.
They're not able to reveal to us humans
why they work or where they fail
and this.
This is a philosophical question for
autonomous vehicles that we may not care
as human beings if the system works well
enough,
but I would argue that it be a long time
before systems work well enough or we
don't care well care and will have to
work together with these systems and
that's where transparency,
communication,
collaboration is critical and edge
cases.
It's all about edge cases in robotics
and autonomous vehicles.
The 99 point nine percent of driving is
really boring.
It's the same especially highway driving
traffic driving.
It's the same.
The obstacle avoidance,
the car following the lane centering.
All of these problems with trivial is
the edge cases,
the trillions of edge cases that need to
be generalized over on a very small
amount of training data.
So again,
I returned to why deep learning.
I mentioned a bunch of challenges and
this is an opportunity.
It's an opportunity to come up with
techniques that opera is successful in
this world,
so I hope the competitions were
presented in this class and the
autonomous vehicle domain.
We'll give you some insight and
opportunity to apply in.
Some of these cases are open research
problems with semantic segmentation of
external perception with control of the
vehicle and deep traffic and with deep
crash of control of the vehicle and
under actuator.
Good high speed conditions and the
driver's state perception.
Okay,
so would that.
I wanted to introduce deep learning to
you today before we get to the fun
tomorrow of autonomous vehicles.
So we'd like to thank and video,
Google auto live,
Toyota and the risk of setting off
people's phones.
Amazon,
Alexa Auto,
but truly I would like to say that I've
been humbled over the past year by the
thousands of messages were received by
the attention by the 18,000
competition entries by the many people
across the world.
Not just here at Mit that are brilliant
that I got a chance to interact with and
I hope we go bigger and do some
impressive stuff in 2018.
Thank you very much and tomorrow is self
driving.